alors comment sortir de cette crise
diplomatique sans précédent avec une
europe qui montre enfin son soutien la
france la donne pourrait-elle changer de
job et d'un est il vraiment entre
d'apaiser les tensions c'est l'objet de
notre décryptage ce soir
[Musique]
nous pour en parler et régis le sommier
grand reporter rt france bonsoir régis
merci d'être avec nous général dominique
trinquant ancien général expert en
géostratégie ancien chef de la mission
un militaire justement à l'onu ancien
conseiller militaire des manuels macron
durant la campagne 2010 est joe biden
qui rappelle donc car son attachement au
multilatéralisme qui dit vouloir
privilégier une coopération entre alliés
mais par un mot sur la crise
diplomatique à l'adresse de la france on
ne l'attendait pas effectivement à la
tribune mais tout de même est ce que les
européens peuvent encore croire joe
biden quand il parle de multilatéralisme
général traquant nous alors
effectivement il ya une succession
d'événements après kaboul les locations
de kaboul et cet incident qui laisse
penser que le multilatéralisme est un
instrument de marketing plus qu'une
réalité
il faut noter la bonne réaction des
européens parce qu'après tout c'est un
contrat français et donc on pourrait
dire les français c'est un contrat
débrouillez vous avec ça or la non les
européens ont bien vu que derrière cette
affaire de contrat il ya un autre sujet
qui est le sujet de l'opposition à la
chine et madame von der leyen le jour où
ce contrat a été annoncé a fait une
déclaration au parlement européen à
strasbourg dans laquelle elle a donné
une autre piste une piste d'une alliance
plus grande et sur d'autres sujets que
les sujets militaires on y reviendra
peut-être mais c'est là l'erreur majeure
des américains c'est d'avoir fait un
focus sur une alliance militaire avec
des australiens et des britanniques
contre la chine au lieu d'élargir
géographiquement au pays d'asier aux
pays européens et les sujets élargie
c'est à dire de ne pas mettre le sujet
militaire en tête mais de mettre
l'économie le numéro le spatial et le
militaire venant en soutien de tout cela
justement on analyse assez conséquent
savoir si c'est une bonne stratégie ou
pas américaine quoi qu'il en soit les
justes le sommier à emmanuel macron un
grand absent de cette réunion à new york
l'allié français ne comptent plus aux
yeux des etats unis on a vraiment ce
sentiment depuis deux jours d'être un
petit peu laissés pour compte clairement
c'est clairement d'un pôle de la part de
la france il ya une déconvenue énorme
c'est un contrat on l'a dit être 50
milliards d'euros c'était aussi un
afflux d'emploi pour les régions
concernées en particulier la région de
cherbourg et également pour les
australiens parce que ce qui est
intéressant c'est quand on analyse en
faites le volte-face qu'ont fait les
australiens choisissant la technologie
américaine et britannique et on se rend
compte finalement que ça va être leur
coûter plus cher que ça va arriver plus
tardivement les clés sous marins
français devaient être livrés en 2030 là
ils ne seront tous livrés qu'en 2040
quand on sait que cette alliance au qu c
est censée justement faire face à la
chine dans cette zone du monde et quand
on connaît le développement en
particulier la marine chinoise qui est
spectaculaire et ultrarapide 2040 c'est
très tard donc en plus il ya la donne
nucléaire que les australiens ont
toujours refusé la veille et ne s'en
d'allergies or la technologie qui va
être utilisé ça va être des dons des des
réacteurs nucléaires donc dans ces sous
marins reactor qu'il n'était pas prévu
dans le volet français même si les
français doté d'une comment apporter aux
australiens et technologies barracuda
toute leur expérience d'évron des
scorpène et des programmes scorpène
ventes au brésil aux robes robes au
pakistan la france a construit près de
250 sous marins le premier sous-marin
français a commencé a été construit en
1899 vous rendez compte donc ce n'est
pas une question d'incompétence
française au contraire et je pense que
la gifle est d'autant plus difficile à
admettre que il et en plus petit détail
qui est qui est sorti également le 15
septembre au moment où toni morrison
donc le premier ministre sera fière
annonce que ce contrat est rompu les
australiens avaient envoyé le même jour
à courrier disant qu'ils étaient
parfaitement satisfait de la capacité
des sous marins français donc voilà donc
là il ya eu effectivement des signes
avant coureurs qui n'ont pas été dépisté
peut-être au niveau du gouvernement il
est quand même difficile de penser que
personne ne savait moi j'avais quand
même quelques infos comme quoi il y
avait un peu d'eau dans le gaz dès le
mois de juillet donc on pouvait voilà
maintenant qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
réellement quel est le fond de cette ce
désaccord l'absence d' emmanuel macron
vous l'avez noté quand même quelque
chose d'assez
régiment de cette absence on va essayer
de voir les choses dans l'ordre
effectivement parce que quand on vous
écoute tous les deux effectivement on se
demande pourquoi pourquoi d'ailleurs
c'est l'argument qui a repris par le
parler français c'est plus cher ça va
mettre plus de temps pourquoi ce volte
face qui devait effectivement être
certainement un petit peu prévu de
longue date je pense que le volte-face
il est dû au parapluie américain c'est à
dire que derrière le contrat il ya les
états unis nos produits protégeront
l'australie où l'australie depuis
plusieurs années est très inquiète de la
montée en puissance de la chine et donc
je pense que c'est cet argument qui a
été avancé plus que effectivement les
contrats le contrat de sous-marins je
rappelle que le contrat pro veut
provoquer 18 mille emplois en australie
or là il y aura pas d'emploi parce que
la technologie elle va rester américaine
elle va être ça va être fabriquée par
les américains ils ne pourront pas le
fabriquée en australie juste un point
alors donnez moi de revenir ancien chef
de la mission militaire à new york donc
de bien connaître l'absence du président
macron n'a rien à voir avec ça le
président macron avait décidé de ne pas
étaler à new york bien avant en revanche
on va voir la sphère du message ça c'est
plus ennuyeux ça peut être liés parce
que vous savez que un message enregistré
comme ça il est envoyé il est prévu à
l'avancé et c'est donc là il n'est pas
impossible que le changement de portage
effet qu' on va pas changer le message
au dernier moment donc on le supprimait
ont réceptionné
l'absence de discussions entre jean yves
le drian tony blinken déjà quand même
assez d'accord qu'est ce que je veux
dire c'est que m on ne peut pas dire que
la rrq ce sens du président macron à new
york soit significative c'est quelque
chose les présidents ne viennent pas
systématiquement les 5 7 ans c'était
quand même qu'un président français se
rendre sauf erreur de ma part je parle
souvent de contrôle 17 ans en 2005
jacques chirac était convalescent à
l'époque ma mini devient écoutez
je me souviens pas qu'à chaque fois il y
avait un président français mais peu
importe on va bien mais c'est pas le
sujet mais le le sujet c'est
qu'effectivement le message à passer
devant l'assemblée ne pouvait pas être
le même donc naturellement il ya 1
chance de l'emporter on va écouter en
tout cas la réaction à l'europe qui a
tardé un petit peu à réagir d'ailleurs
silence assourdissant aussi d' emmanuel
macron on sent un certain embarras
autour de cette affaire font propose
d'écouter joseph
lors des discussions les ministres ont
exprimé explicitement leur solidarité à
l'égard de la france et cette annonce de
l'alliance à hocus et de l'accord sur
les sous marins australiens va à
l'encontre des appels à une plus grande
coopération avec l'union européenne dans
la région indo pacifique à la
coopération dans la région du pacifique
un c'est là tout le noeud de cette
affaire la france qui sont d'ailleurs
pouvoir compter sur sur l'inde
désormais c'était le message des manuels
macro aujourd'hui tout à fait il ya une
rencontre d'ailleurs entre les ministres
dont curieux le drian et sont à son
homologue indien là on peut imaginer
aussi qu' il ya des contrats d'armement
aussi qu'ils sont en préparation très
certainement il dirait pas qu'il y aura
recyclage des sous marins avec l'inde
mais la vente c'est n'a plus que neuf
sous marins qui sont aux capacités
opérationnelles sur une vingtaine dans
sa flotte il est évident qu'il ya un an
à fort besoin de la part de l'inde
également de se doter d'une arme
nucléaire une arme sous marine efficace
et moderne donc là il ya peut-être en
effet déjà des discussions entre la
france et l'inde pour peut-être signer
un contrat potentiel à nouveau avec la
marine indienne alizée oui oui vous
parliez de du silence du président
macron le président macron à l'évidence
d'abord attendre parler avec monsieur
brydon pour voir ce qu'ils ont à se dire
deuxième point lui a parlé aussi au
premier ministre indien donc je reviens
à la stratégie face à la chine elle doit
inclure les européens ils viennent de
déclarer que la position n'était pas
acceptable et sont un soutien de la
france et ça doit inclure également les
pays asiatiques dont le plus lourd et
l'inde je rappelle qu'il a acheté des
rafales
aujourd'hui il est en train de discuter
de racheter des mirage 2000 refit t
puisque en inde il ya une industrie
aéronautique de très haut niveau je suis
allé moi-même visiter les usines de très
haut niveau et vous aviez raison sur les
sous-marins ya des discussions sur des
sous-marins un peu similaire c'est à
dire des sous-marins attaques des
sous-marins de type par un coude a en
tout cas le chef de la diplomatie
française lui dénonce une rupture de
confiance nous dénonce une orientation
très confrontation elle dit est des
états unis il estime désormais que les
européens devraient défendre un modèle
elle perd natif alors la question est
aujourd'hui quel est ce modèle
alternatif et surtout quelles sont les
options on l'a véritablement
envisageable pour la france aujourd'hui
le vrai constat dans cette histoire
c'est quand même là c'est une sorte de
mini tragédie européenne ou en tout cas
de démonstration de l'inexistence de
l'europe en tout cas sur le plan
international de 2 sa capacité à
s'émerveiller à émerger et à constituer
une force commune dans la diplomatie
parce que ce qu'on se rend compte c'est
que à part éventuellement revenir
timidement parce qu'on n'a pas vu les
allemands très à l'offensive non plus
pour venir aider la france dans cette
histoire donc ce qu'on se rend compte en
revanche c'est que les anglais qui donc
ont subi leur exit et à qui on
promettait justement la ruine économique
est bien sentir très bien puisqu'ils
sont associés à ce contrat ils sont 11
nous en sommes exclus donc là une
nouvelle fois les anglais marquent à
point diplomatiquement il prouve une
nouvelle fois qu'il reste le seul allié
des américains
en tout cas le l'allié historique et que
c'est pas nous c'est allier la donc le
là il ya un vrai peut-être une une vraie
réflexion à avoir sur
dragon n'est pas d'accord avec vous mais
l'europe est totalement inexistant alors
et j'ai lu ça dans les astres voilà
comme je suis absolument pas d'accord et
je la voulais m'en mêler gérer non effet
démontré celui démontré que j'ai cités
que le 15 madame von der leyen a ébauché
le plan européen de politique
stratégique dans la zone indo pacifique
donc elle l'exprimé deuxième point les
européens se sont exprimées aujourd'hui
frontalement avec les allemands contre
la position américaine en disant nous ne
sommes pas d'accord donc ce que je pense
à la réalité sont là on est lancé en
décembre donc le 21 décembre
l'europe contre l'europe proposition le
jour où les américains ont annoncé cet
accord donc elle a pris position
deuxièmement aujourd'hui assemblée
générale des nations unies les européens
ont pris position donc je pense que les
européens ont pris position il y à un
réveil européen pourquoi parce que la
naïveté qui consistait à dire après
l'horreur de tremble enfin un bail d'un
an arrive on va jouer le
multilatéralisme ils s'aperçoivent que
ça marche pas sur les britanniques
imaginez vous que je suis sur une chaîne
plutôt tendance russe j'interviens
beaucoup sur les radios britanniques
c'est très très intéressant de les
écouter il y avait dix quoi ils vous
disent après kaboul il ya eu deux jours
de débats au parlement britannique où on
a dit ça suffit la special relationship
ça marche pas il faut arrêter ce truc là
mais en même temps beau et johnson qui a
quand même changé de gouvernement ou
même moment je le rappelle donc il est
en difficulté sort du chapeau cet accord
avec les américains et c'est en
contradiction avec une bonne partie de
son parti qui disent aujourd'hui il y en
a assez donc je pense que bobby jackson
joue sorolla rien à dire il joue son
rôle en disant vous avez la special
relationship
le dis à chaque fois la special
relationship ça ne marche que dans un
sens le sens américain et arrêter de
placer une étoile de plus sur le drapeau
américain donc aujourd'hui les européens
son réveil on va voir jusqu'où ça va on
va voir comment les américains
finalement écoute ce langage cantal
affaires britannique ils sont très vexé
parce qu'on a pas rapatrier le
l'ambassadeur de france qui est en
grande bretagne je leur ai dit sur les
chaînes anglaises j'avais le sentiment
parce que je ne comptais pas ne comptait
pas c'est les etats-unis qui veulent
protéger l'australie et ils ont rajouté
un troisième pays dans la sphère
pourquoi parce que les sous-marins
nucléaires américains ne seront pas
vendus directement par les américains
mais avec l'aide des britanniques c'est
à dire que c'est un go between ou
quelqu'un est ce que ça ira parce que
c'est beaucoup de politiques de
responsables politiques français le
demandent aujourd'hui jusqu'à un retrait
du commandement intégré de l'otan moi je
suis tout à fait favorable je veux dire
j'ai je pense que c'était une erreur de
reprendre de commandes de contrarier ce
qui avait été décidé en 66 par le
général de gaulle c'est à dire la clé de
notre indépendance et la dissuasion on a
des alliés on est intégré en effet dans
un système d'alliances mais on n'avait
aucune raison de le faire et depuis on
n'a fait que du suivisme vis-à-vis des
etats-unis le problème c'est qu'on se
rend compte avec cette histoire on se
rend compte avec l'afghanistan également
que les décisions ne sont pas prises en
concertation avec nous que il ya une
comment une arme non inouïe à mépris en
tout cas n'ont eu un strict respect de
la part des américains de leurs intérêts
uniquement et c'est à dire qu'en fait là
dedans on se rend compte que nous on est
censé dire amen on est censé a commandé
que les états unis décident quelque
chose les suivre la seule fois on les a
pas suivis c'est en 2003 au moment de
l'invasion d'irak et ça a été peut-être
notre plus notre dernière véritable
manifestation d'indépendance nationale
ou en tout cas où la france a brillé sur
la scène internationale depuis ça n'a
été que des commandes du suivisme et il
serait peut-être temps aujourd'hui quand
on voit l'émergence d'autres puissances
je pense par exemple à la turquie je
pense par exemple à la russie ou à
d'autres éventuellement que la france
redéfinissent quelque peu ses alliances
et 16 cette espèce d'atlantisme
permanent emmanuel macron au début de
son quinquennat j'en appelle à
manifester attendez je termine emmanuel
macron au début de son quinquennat avait
accueilli vladimir poutine à versailles
avait entamé le dialogue du trianon il y
avait un début voilà de dialogue ça n'a
pas été concrétisée depuis
le suivi rappelé puisqu'on parle de
l'afghanistan que les français ont
quitté l'afghanistan entre 2011 et 2014
donc si vous voulez la feuille que de
trajectoire il n'était pas d'accord ils
sont partis donc ya pas de suivi ce
premier point deuxième point pourquoi
l'otan est stratégique pour nous parce
que pour parler avec les pays européens
si nous ne sommes pas dans le temps nous
ne sommes pas écoutés
les pays européens il se trouve que dans
mes missions précédentes j'étais
responsable de la coopération avec les
pays européens les pays européens sont
aux trois quarts tous dans le temps si
vous êtes à l'extérieur de l'otan il
vous écoute même pas ils disent non mais
attendez la france c'est comme
d'habitude et c'est sur la politique
française alternative vous aviez raison
de signes et de signaler l'invitation de
monsieur poutine il a été invité dans
seulement un versailles il a été
également dans la résidence d'été du
président et je j'interviens souvent sur
ce jeu de gala jeudi on a fait beaucoup
de pas qu'est ce que vous avez fait de
votre côté messieurs les russes que
faites vous pour vous rapprocher de nous
chaque fois qu'on se rapproche de vous
ça se bloque donc je dis que la france
comme le dit le président macron est une
puissance d' équilibre elle n'est pas
suivie au derrière les américains elle
est capable et je le dis souvent aux
américains parce que nous sommes vos
amis nous sommes capables de dire le
contraire de ce que vous pensez ce qu'on
a fait en 2003 également et sur
l'afghanistan je rappelle on n'a pas
suivi du tout on est on est intervenue
en 2001 à cause de oussama ben laden
quand oussama ben laden est mort nous
avons quitté avec les troupes de combat
d'afghanistan parce que nous
considérions que nous n'avions plus rien
à faire mais la suite de l'opération est
ce que c'est le moment de relancer
justement cette défense commune
européenne qui a du plomb zinc a du mal
à sa guérison elle a du mal pourquoi je
l'expliquais on revient de loin je
rappelle que les pays de l'est européen
ont été sous l'occupation soviétique
pendant des années et lorsque vous leur
parlez de la russie ça reste toujours le
vilain ordre qui est de l'autre côté on
a du mal à les convaincre aujourd'hui
ils sont entrain découvrir le sahel et
avec la force takouba ils sont en train
de découvrir que la menace est plutôt
ici qu'ailleurs donc on a beaucoup de
mal la pédagogie est difficile et il se
sent toujours abrité derrière le
parapluie américain mais à force de
bévues pardonnez-moi américaine sur
l'afghanistan et celle là les européens
sont en train de découvrir que les
américains ne s'intéresse plus qu'à une
chose à la chine pour nous la menace
elle et au moyen-orient et au sahel et
donc ils ont intérêt à se concentrer là
dessus donc ça va prendre du temps c'est
certain mais ça avance progressivement
le mot de la fin pour vous régis le
sommier nouveau cv on aurait pu faire un
face à face ce soir au lieu d'avoir
écrit parfois
je ne vois pas où ça avance je pense que
là on a on a un vrai problème au sel on
a un vrai problème au moyen-orient au
moyen-orient ça a eu je veux dire le la
lgv est la volonté des engagements des
américains allaient manifeste pour pour
toute la zone du moyen-orient et se se
désengage de d'afghanistan aujourd'hui
parce qu'ils n'ont plus d'intérêt
laissant finalement d'autres pays comble
et comblé les vides et redéfinir la
carte géopolitique de toutes ces régions
et terminer ses interventions des états
unis mais en attendant d'autres sont la
manoeuvre prenez la turquie elle est
présente sur ces fronts différents la
turquie est encore elle va récupérer
probablement la gestion de la sécurité
de l'aéroport de kaboul l'aéroport hamid
karzaï ce qui va lui donner encore sonné
or le qatar qui la wii mais m'est avis
qu'il va lui donner encore une sphère
vague d'expansion et au niveau
économique en afghanistan elle avait
déjà placé ses pions donc si vous voulez
il ya il ya quand même une réalité
géopolitique aujourd'hui qui ce qui
serait d'anti serait à mon avis
nécessaire de prendre compte de
l'existence c'est à dire hé hé hé et de
ce point de vue là d'arrêter peut-être
les les logiciels anciens d'autant plus
qu'on voit que quand on est bas avec les
états unis on se fait humilier voilà
c'est ce qui s'est passé la france est
humilié aujourd'hui et vous paye pas le
dire le contraire
vous voulez que je dise à dernier si
vous voulez vous parler de la turquie et
a pris place importante en particulier
en syrie grâce à l'alliance avec la
russie je le rappelle donc n'ya pas du
blanc et du noir je veux dire il ya des
zones un peu grise et quant à la
position de la france quant à la
position de la france je le répète elle
a une position d'équilibré elle cherche
à rendre les européens responsables ça
va prendre du temps mais ça vient il ya
un fonds européen de défense il ya un
fonds european p tout ceci n'existait
pas 7 milliards sur le fond européen de
défense 7 milliards sur le fond
européenne paie il ya cinq ans on
pouvait pas en parler donc ça avance
mais ça avance lentement parce que nous
avons 27 histoire différente autour de
la table merci en tout cas tous les deux
pour ce décryptage animé qui était un
face-à-face merci en tout cas vous au
moins vous aurez exprimé deux points de
vue effectivement merci